bonsoir messieurs merci beaucoup d'être
là ce soir pour débattre sur ce plateau
d' rt france je m'adresse tout d'abord
avoue frédéric jeanjean
pensez vous que les petits commerces
doivent rester ouverts écoutez ce que
nous pouvons dire c'est que nous avons
constaté que des maires lancé des appels
la situation est très complexe on sait
qu'une épidémie
on sait qu'il ya un véritable danger on
sait qu'à côté de ça il va y avoir une
mise à mort de tout le tissu économique
et je parle des tpe des pme
donc il faut arriver à trouver des
solutions la difficulté c'est que nous
avons essayé nous à marseille nous avons
été les premiers à avoir été fermés dans
nos établissements cafés hôtels et
restaurants nous avions essayé discuter
avec le gouvernement
nous avons affaire à des gens qui sont
des technocrates sont froids et il faut
engager le rapport de forces qu'on
pouvoir pour pouvoir discuter
à l'heure actuelle nous avons encore de
revendication
nous avons des revendications pour
pouvoir sauver le tissu économique
et si on veut sauver le tissu économique
j'entends ici et là qu'on nous dit c'est
pas ce que voulait sauver votre tiroir
caisse
je rappellerai simplement que nos
activités et la consommation dans son
ensemble parce que cela génère permet de
payer les retraites
la maladie et le chômage en france et
que c'est tout cet ensemble là qui va
être mise à mal
alors on veut briser la société on peut
envoyer les gens vers les livres ou pour
la restauration on peut les envoyer vers
amazon pour acheter on peut les envoyer
dans la grande distribution parce que
c'est plus facile à surveiller à
coordonner à contrôler mais on ne peut
pas empêcher la vie on ne peut pas
empêcher la vie et je voudrais faire des
discours qui avait été fait par des
parlementaires l'assemblée qui disait il
nous faut apprendre à vivre malgré le
virus est ce que c'est une ré est ce que
vaut le décret et frédéric donjon c'est
valable aussi pour les restaurants très
court pour les restaurants nous avons
mis en place un protocole sanitaire qui
est très claire dans aucune étude en
france on nous dit que c'est dans nos
établissements que le virus se transmet
alors on nous dit maintenant il faut
réduire les relations sociales
on entend quand ils auraient transports
en commun
les gens m'ont emmené les enfants à
l'école vont continuer à les travailler
enfin bon à un moment il faudrait un peu
de cohérence et eric straumann ai faites
vous partie de ces mères qui ont pris
des arrêtés justement pour permettre aux
petits commerces de leur commune de
rester ouvert justement pour ne pas les
laisser mourir
j'ai beaucoup hésité hier soir encore
les commerçants avaient sollicité en
mettant en avant un certain nombre
d'arguments je sais que ce type d'années
est d'arrêter et évidemment contestable
juridiquement je ne voulais pas non plus
donner de faux espoirs à mes commerçants
mais la réalité sur le terrain fait
qu'aujourd'hui je ne touche aujourd'hui
pas expliquer la politique du
gouvernement
j'ai un magasin de jouets ont centre
ville de colmar qui est fermée qui a
stocké sa marchandise et qui attend de
pouvoir ouvrir éventuellement vent noël
c'est un magasin qui au s'organisait
pour permettre la délivrance de la
marchandise dans toutes les conditions
sanitaires prescrites et bien ce magasin
est fermé et les gens vont aujourd'hui
htc s'est jouée dans l'est dans les
grandes surfaces et je n'ai aucun
argument objectif
d'ailleurs on va plutôt concentré tous
les acheteurs dans les grandes surfaces
alors que si on s'organise en centre
ville où les on peut faire faire la
queue aux gens à l'extérieur des
magasins avec le port du masque et
toutes les règles de distanciation et
notamment le gel je pense que le risque
est objectivement plus faible dans les
petits commerces de centre ville où il
ya cinq-six le client en simultané que
dans les grandes surfaces où on a bien
plus de monde et cet argument c'est un
argument fife actuelle on va le défendre
devant le tribunal même si je sais que
c'est difficile alors les faits aussi de
ces arrêtés c'est que ça ça peut même
pas mal remuer auprès des
administrations bien entendu le préfet
bad effet raymond arrêté comme suit des
trente et trente autres maires qui ont
pris même type d'arrêté devant le
tribunal administratif
si c'est l'occasion d'un débat sur
l'organisation
l'organisation de ce confinement
bien entendu je suis favorable mesures
les plus strictes lorrains étaient très
touchés lors de la première période par
le codi de 19 on a eu des centaines de
bord d'un autre département
aujourd'hui la situation s'est améliorée
alors je ne sais pas si c'est lié à une
forme d'immunité collective mère je me
suis convaincu qu'on peut permettre
l'ouverture des petits commerces sans
créer un risque particulier de
développement du coc vide en respectant
bien entendu un certain nombre de règles
et en évitant la concentration dans les
grandes surfaces
lorsque vous prenez un chariot vous
prenez déjà un risque lorsque vous avez
lorsque vous rentrez dans le commerce
etc on trouvait des marchandises le
risque infiniment plus faibles j'espère
que le gouvernement va prendre
conscience de cette situation
je sais que bruno le maire et travaille
le sujet et on va trouver une solution
au moins pour ce type de commerce au
courant du début de la semaine prochaine
mais c'est si je ne trouve le ministre
d'économie avait plaidé justement pour
sauver ces petits commerces pour qu'il
reste ouvert
ils ont moins de trésorerie que les
grands groupes finalement frédéric
jeanjean est ce que c'est pas eux qu'on
aurait dû sauver avant de laisser ouvert
les grandes surfaces par exemple pour
ces raisons trésorerie et de faillite
écoutez les grandes surfaces joue sur le
fait qu' il faut travailler sur
l'alimentation de la population
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
maires discuter avec eux ici dans le
département des bouches du rhône le
comité départemental du tourisme avait
mis en jeu pour un montant de 300 mille
euros des passes à gagner pour manger au
restaurant en emporter en livrer ou sur
place à l'époque où nous étions ouverts
il ya tout un tas d'initiatives a lancé
pour soutenir le commerce de proximité
parce que vous savez nous dans nos
activités
eux nous ne défiscalisant bas dont nous
restons sur place
2 c'est une pérennité et vous avez des
familles entières qui vivent par nos
activités parce que vous avez des
salariés vous avez des chefs
d'entreprise vous avez et c'est tout un
tissu qu'on est en train de mettre à mal
alors on voudrait du berry geste société
honda la standardiser
qu'avec des normes c'est la facilité
technocratiquement ça passe bien sur le
papier
dans les faits ça va poser énormément de
soucis je vais vous dire les choses
comme elles sont à l'heure actuelle je
tire la sonnette d'alarmé parce que je
pense que d'ici quelques semaines nous
allons nous retrouver avec des émeutes
de la faim en france et je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple il ya
quantité de magasins autour de mon
établissement où les vendeurs et
vendeuses travail on fixe et ensuite une
grosse part variable
là ce mois ci leurs commerces étaient
ouverts ils vont pouvoir toucher leur
salaire à la fin du mois de novembre
la part variable aura disparu et nous
allons nous trouver avec les chefs
d'entreprises en tpe pme qui eux n'ont
pas le chômage partiel
ils n'ont pas de couverture on leur a
proposé 1500 euros transformable en dix
mille euros
il faut voir la paperasse qui est à
remplir il faut voir les délais nous ça
fait six semaines qu'on nous a promis
tout un tas dead à marseille
quand monsieur veron et monsieur galilée
était venu monsieur castex a dit il ya
une semaine de ça lundi matin ce sera
fait mardi au plus tard
on attend toujours les décrets donc vous
savez c'est au quotidien après il faut
faire bouillir la marmite et carly faire
bouillir la marmite il faut faire ses
courses il faut pouvoir avancer et là je
pense qu'à la fin du mois de novembre et
à l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année on
va arriver sur quelque chose de très
tendue vous avez tous les gens qui ont
des petits boulots au tour tous les gens
qui étaient en sortir qu'ils ne peuvent
plus sortir du fait du confinement
vous avez tous ces paramètres là qui
vont générer derrière une crise sociale
qui sera aussi une crise économique et
il y aura beaucoup plus de morts des
conséquences de cette politique là que
du conte vite je pense eric straumann
c'est votre c'est ce que vous entendez
parmi les personnes qui veulent garder
leurs commerces ouverts dans votre
commune
la faillite est aujourd'hui dans une
suie pas dans une ville de la taille de
marseille évidemment c'est une petite
file et vous savez que dans l'est dans
les villes moyennes
on a des difficultés pour maintenir on
vit les commerces de centre-ville alors
colmar
toujours bénéficié d'une situation
plutôt favorable en raison de la
fréquentation touristique
mais là on risque de franchir un seuil
qui va tout simplement faire apparaître
de nombreux commerces du centre-ville
assécher l'offre commerciale de
centre-ville et et on aura des rideaux
qui sont tiré et personne n'a intérêt à
ce que nous centre ville disparaissent
au profit du commerce de banlieue c'est
un modèle aussi à sauver jeu faut je
pense que le gouvernement doit en avoir
conscience parce que dans nos villes
moyennes beaucoup de commerces sont
totalement dépendants des fêtes de fin
d'année des bijouteries des vagues à les
magasins textile et la marge réalisée en
fin d'année autour des pe de noël et si
ces magasins sont fermés durant cette
période
malheureusement pas de marge et c'est
tout simplement la disparition de ces
commerces ce qui nous guette et le
gouvernement qui voulait privilégier
aussi l'industrie de proximité c'est le
cas pour ces petits commerces
ce serait la mort aussi de ce principe
qu'on avait défendu pendant le premier
confinement et restera c'est surtout la
wii c'est surtout en fait l'alimentation
de proximité ça par contre ça a très
bien fonctionné nous avons des
maraîchers sur colmar on a des filières
courtes qui fonctionne très très bien et
d'ailleurs on sent la population a
décidé de retour revenir vers les
commerces locaux
on a nos marchés qui fonctionne très
bien depuis la fin du déconfinement et
d'ailleurs je remercie gouvernement qui
a décidé de maintenir ses marchés on
s'en souvient lors sous 2 lors de la
première période de confinement les
marchés étaient fermés ce qui était une
mauvaise chose puisque là encore ça
profité aux grandes surfaces donc le
gouvernement à avancer sur ce sujet
parce que je pense qu'on ne prend pas
plus de risques en allant sur un marché
qu'on à l'amp dans un supermarché allons
faire un pas encore un peu plus loin
pour que cette rupture d'égalité entre
les grandes surfaces et des petits
commerçants ben disparaissent c'est pour
permettre l'achat rld est toujours dans
les règles de confinement dans les
règles de distanciation sociale dans les
règles sanitaires sans prendre aucun
risque supplémentaire permettons à ces
commerces non alimentaires de travailler
en cette période de noël
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions directes
sur rt france